[Musik]
oder Impfdosen abgelaufen die lagern bei
minus 25 Grad Energie die man sich wohl
sparen könnte und gleichzeitig schlagen
die apothekenalarm viele wichtige
Medikamente Fehlen eines der Themen
heute hier bei uns bei viertel nach acht
mit spannenden Gästen auf die ich mich
freue was produziert Deutschland
eigentlich noch selbst fragt Politikerin
und Energieexpertin Antje Hermenau sie
fürchtet Deutschland verspielt seine
Zukunft essen oder heizen vor dieser
Wahl stehen immer mehr Menschen in
Großbritannien der berichtet die Fazit
mein bildkollege Viktor wax hat lange in
Großbritannien gelebt und sagt die Lage
ist wirklich dramatisch auf der Insel
droht das auch uns zu aktuellen Debatte
zur Einbürgerung sprechen wir mit Autor
Thomas Fassbender er sagt Europa stehe
vor einer großen Zeitenwende die
Journalistin susanne Gaschke klopft
heute der Regierung auf die Finger und
sagt Regierung hört auf den Menschen zu
sagen wie sie zu leben haben und
verbrennt dafür nicht auch noch aber
Millionen Euro Steuergelder
ja ich habe es eben erwähnt 4,6
Millionen abgelaufene Impfdosen lagern
bei -25 Grad das gab das
Gesundheitsministerium auf Anfrage von
fDP-Vize Wolfgang Kubicki bekannt eine
Begründung aus dem Hause Lauterbach
warum diese Massen an Impfstoff nicht
schon längst entsorgt werden ja man
könne eventuell eine Verlängerung der
Haltbarkeit erreichen ein Thema über das
wir hier heute sprechen wollen frei
haben wir noch sie sind Energieexpertin
ist das nicht eine Milchmädchenrechnung
naja also man könnte natürlich noch
diese Dosen jetzt einfach weg tun wenn
sie verbraucht sind nicht mehr braucht
werden können ich bin der Meinung dass
man sowieso viel zu viel gekauft hat und
ich bin auf der Meinung dass man
insgesamt bei Corona drastisch
übertrieben hat wir haben ja nicht nur
diese Frage des bisschen Energie um die
kühl zu halten wir haben ganz viele
andere Sachen auch verbockt in zwei
Jahren und die Unternehmer müssen das
ausbaden also ich denke das Corona
vorbei ist ich glaube auch nicht dass
das jetzt in dem Maße wiederkommen wir
brauchen auch keine Impfdosen mehr dafür
sieht der Gesundheitsminister wie wir
gerade gesehen haben ganz anders haben
sie noch irgendwas im Keller was sie da
vielleicht noch gekühlt was Sie nicht
mehr brauchen aber ich finde das ist
schon ein richtiger Punkt also das ist
ich glaube auch also ich weiß nicht wie
viel Energie man braucht um diese Dosen
jetzt zu kühlen aber das ist tatsächlich
ein Symbol dafür dass man dass man also
ständig auf Overkill gesetzt hat dass
man und wir können ganz bestimmt jetzt
nicht so weitermachen also es hat ja so
viele Zweifel an der Impfung tatsächlich
auch gegeben an den Nebenwirkungen das
wird jetzt alles langsam diskutiert ich
war immer sehr fürs m-impfen insofern
müssen wir fairerweise sagen wir haben
natürlich den Lauterbach auch gedrängt
also wir haben oder dann damals sparen
gedrängt also wir wollen wir brauchen
jetzt endlich Impfstoff warum kommt der
nicht andere Informationen die man
damals hatte nämlich dass die Impfung
von der Ansteckung schützt
wahrscheinlich auch hat man da
vielleicht also ein bisschen überzogen
ist auch Nummer sicher gegangen aber
jetzt was soll's das heißt wenn er was
glauben Sie kannst du dieser Fehlplanung
kommen
Pandemie machen ja der Skandal ist ja
nicht dass 4,6 Millionen zu viel gekauft
worden sind das Skandal ist mit die ist
ist jeder Tag die diese 4,6 Millionen
offiziell abgelaufen gek werden und
liegen und er das riecht weil wir diese
dieser Ausrede wir suchen jetzt eine
Möglichkeit dass irgendwie zu verlängern
also wenn wenn Edeka das jetzt sagen
würde für die abgelaufenen Lebensmittel
dann gibt es sonst was ja wenn Sie den
Joghurt dann noch kaufen
aber wo ist der Politiker der jetzt
einfach sagt okay Leute wir haben vor
ein zwei Jahren Fehler gemacht ja das
wird doch jeder verstehen weil keiner
das besser machen kann aber jetzt muss
eine Entscheidung ja dann wenn da 4,6
Millionen ranzige Schweinehälften hängen
ja und gekühlt werden dann kommen die
tierkörperverwertungsanstalt da muss
eine Entscheidung her ja und nicht so
eine faule Ausrede ja wir haben noch
eine wir suchen noch einen Weg die
schweinehälter die das Ganze zu
entfernen aber auch eine Entschuldigung
ach Entschuldigung ja über werden
Bekenntnisse entschuldigen gefordert ich
bin kein Freund von ich bin Freund von
Maßnahmen und von Wahrheit man muss
zugeben wenn Fehler gemacht worden sind
wenn wenn bestimmte Lage bestimmte also
bestimmte Maßnahmen erfordern müssen die
definiert und GE werden und durchgezogen
werden so gewinnt man auch das Vertrauen
der Bürger wieder also das Vertrauen ist
doch etwas tiefer verletzt glaube ich
bei vielen Leuten wenigstens im Drittel
der Bevölkerung nach meinem Dafürhalten
und dann müsste man also ein einfacher
wie tut mir leid habe ich mich geirrt
wird nicht reichen entschuldigung das
geht nicht aber zu sagen wir haben da
auch überzogen wir haben da auch nicht
auf die anderen gehört wir haben den
Disput nicht zugelassen damit es tut
nicht zugelassen und das halte ich für
ganz wichtig wir werden jetzt immer mehr
Leute mit im Schäden haben die Debatte
wird also sowieso kommen und die Frage
ist wie lange die Politik die vor sich
herschieben will natürlich hat man am
Anfang erstmal alles gemacht das finde
ich auch richtig wenn du nicht weißt
womit es zu tun hast gehst erstmal auf
Nummer sicher und wartest ne und die
älteren Leute im Lande haben sich auch
ein bisschen beschützt gefühlt das muss
auch sagen aber jetzt gucken Sie doch
mal wenn es jetzt gerade alles trifft
mit den impfte und wer das ist welche
Alter und die Kinder haben sich weniger
beschützen also unsere Ministerpräsident
Sachsen hat gesagt wir hätten die Kitas
und Schulen nicht schließen müssen das
war ein Fehler die haben sich langsam so
ein bisschen in Richtung tut uns leid
aber es gibt keine klare Auswertungen
was viele Leute erlebt haben war dass
sie drangsaliert worden sind die wurden
von ihren Jobs entfernt den wurde
angekündigt dass sie vielleicht
eingesperrt werden sie haben bestimmte
Bereiche im Leben nicht betreten dürfen
es ist war richtig hart das würde
Diktatur ausgeräumt
hier klar gibt's diese diese Frage
inwieweit die Politik Masken Impfung und
so weiter berechtigt war nicht
berechtigt war ja die gibt es sowieso
aber hier haben wir ja mal ein konkretes
Problem okay 4,6 Millionen Abgeordneten
da kann die Politik mal zeigen sie kann
was tun und sie kann was bewegen und
damit würde auch schon ein Stückchen ich
gebe zu die ganze wird das Ganze
Vertrauen in die Politik würde damit
nicht wiedergekommen werden aber ein
Stückchen wäre es und es ist nichts
Besonderes
oder Karl Lauterbach ich glaube wir alle
wissen ganz normal ist er nicht das
denke ich kann man so sagen es gibt
Leute denken er hat eine Macke ob das
stimmt weiß ich nicht aber es ist für
mich wie ein griechischer tragischer
Held der nicht eingestehen kann dass er
hier falsch lag und jetzt druckst du
darum gesagt er hofft auf irgendeine
Verlängerung dass die vielleicht doch
noch haltbar sind und deswegen will er
sie nicht aus der Kühlkammer rausholen
ja und ist einfach so jemand der so
festgefahren in seinen Meinungen ist
dass er da nicht raus kann es gibt
einige Schlüssel sozusagen einer
Sackgasse er hat einen Trip gemacht nach
Israel dieses Jahr wir haben bei Bild
groß darüber berichtet da hat er in dem
Flieger dahin nach Tel Aviv Schokolade
gefunden und dann gesagt einer von
unseren Reporterin war dabei und dann
hat er gesagt wer hat hier Schokolade
mitgebracht das ist so ungesund dann
hatte die alle eingesagt wieso irrer ja
als Minister und diese Anekdote hat
finde ich gezeigt
der der ist so wie sie sagen genau aber
ich finde Lauterbach ist ein Thema
tatsächlich aber es waren schon mehr
Leute die Brust tun der Überzeugung und
da gehört die ehemalige Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel und definitiv auch dazu
und ihr Kanzleramtsminister und alle
haben geredet im brustturm der
Überzeugung mit großem Phase und jetzt
wird halt wieder vermieden also hier ist
es vergleichsweise Detailprobleme mit
den Impfdosen aber auch Lauterbach
vermeidet jetzt wieder sorgfältig
irgendwie zuzugeben dass irgendwas nicht
richtig und nicht gut war mir geht's gar
nicht so sehr um die Entschuldigung
sondern mir geht es darum die haben in
einer sehr unsicheren Situation das
gestehen wir Ihnen alle zu das man
konnte es nicht genau wissen getan als
ob sie ganz genau wissen was sie tun und
das mit mit großer Betonung und und auch
moralischer Keule durchgezogen jeder der
abweichende Meinung hatte wollte
eigentlich alte Leute umbringen
werden haben sie ihre Einstellung zum
Impfen auch im Zuge der Pandemie
verändert ich finde eine Sache vorher
also ich will gar keine Entschuldigung
dafür kann man sich gar nicht
entschuldigen man kann sich unverzeihung
werden aber auch das muss nicht sein
aber ein Wort das dauert
geworden deswegen frage ich Sie das ob
sie auch in das ist ja dann auch der
Punkt ob sie auch das Überdenken dass
anders
breiter ist und dass man offensichtlich
dass im Schäden irgendwie vorkommen und
dass man doch darüber reden muss und es
ist ja auch es ist ja auch naheliegend
also es war ein vollkommen neues
Medikament das ganz schnell
in die Praxis gedrückt wurde und es ist
es wäre fast lebensfremd zu sagen dass
da nicht später noch noch zusätzliche
Erkenntnisse auftauchen und sie ist dann
im Rückblick dafür geworden zu haben ich
habe
also ich glaube immer noch ja ich weiß
gar nicht ich war nie für die
Impfpflicht ich glaube ich war
zwischendurch mal aber ganz kurz hat
diese abwegigen Standpunkt also im Sinne
von ja wenn man das nicht machen lässt
dann kann man weiß ich nicht dann dann
dann kein Krankengeld oder irgend so ein
Scheiß habe ich mal geschrieben aber das
war glaube ich wirklich nur einmal aber
es ist ja also es ist ja viel Schaden
angerichtet worden also und zwar also
wie bei der Impfung wissen wir das Ende
der Geschichte noch gar nicht glaub
schon dass sie gewirkt hat im Sinne von
weniger Todesfälle das haben wir schon
gesehen also nach der zweiten Welle mit
tausend Toten am Tag das hatten wir
schon alle das Gefühl oh wow und das ist
jetzt ein bisschen viel und das ist
danach ja dramatisch also als dann
durchgeimpft wurde zurückgegangen man
kriegt ja offensichtlich trotzdem drei
bis viermal so also habe ich kenne Leute
die hatten die sind Folge geimpft und
haben es viermal jetzt schon gehabt also
das ist noch eine offene Geschichte aber
andere Sachen wissen wir jetzt wir
wissen dass die Kita und Schuld also bei
den kinderschließungen sogar durch eine
Studie bei den Schulschließung kann man
das analog relativ wahrscheinlich
vermuten dass die völlig unbegründet
waren weil Ansteckung dort unterhalb der
Ansteckung in den Familien lag aber wir
wissen jetzt auch was die Schäden bei
den Kindern und Jugendlichen angerichtet
haben
das war schlimm und das war auch falsch
das machen auch nicht wieder und das
würden wir genauso auch nicht wieder
machen und und darauf warte ich also die
ganze Zeit und genau von der Lauterbach
ist zu erwarten ist wahrscheinlich das
hoffnungslos aber Frau Merkel wir
erinnern uns alle an die osterruhe
erinnern entschuldigt hat sich
entschuldigt und deswegen muss man da
ein bisschen skalieren in diesem blaming
jetzt hinterher oh keiner hat sich bei
uns entschuldigt es gibt so Leute
diese Entscheidung revidiert und sich
für die Entscheidung entschuldigt und
auch gehandelt das muss man genau merken
aber sich dann einmal da hinzustellen
vor dem Bundestag und zu sagen sorry es
war mein Fehler das hat sie so gesagt
war mein Fehler alleine war schon groß
in der Situation
ich glaube wenn diese Erfahrung ein
gutes hat ja und dann sollte es unter da
sind also alle Öffentlichkeit beteiligt
sind ja auch aufgerufen
wir sollten endlich einmal zu diesem zu
diesem Dogma zurückkehren voller Designs
ja was ja nicht nur hier als Hammer
benutzt wird als Vorschlag haben wir um
und missliebige oder abweichende Meinung
tot zu schlagen es gibt kein keine
wissenschaftliche wahrheitsdogmatik ja
und Wissenschaft lernt genauso wie wir
alle außerhalb der Wissenschaft auch
lernen
wenn wir wenn wir die Politiker dazu
auffordern jetzt treten vor und sagt am
Beispiel von Corona follow the science
deckt vielleicht 95% ab aber die
entscheidenden 5% nicht also da muss man
ihn glaube ich ganz genau auf die Finger
gucken vor allem weiß natürlich auch
eine wahnsinnige Geldverschwendung war
die ganzen Tests die ganzen Masken das
hat wahnsinnig viel gekostet jetzt liegt
dort gekühlt Millionen von Impfdosen
auch das kostet Energie jetzt in einer
Energiekrise und währenddessen auch ein
ganz großes Thema bei uns zu Gast
vergessen jung und sie sagte jeder
zweite Patient bekommt nicht mehr die
Medikamente die er braucht schon einmal
in diesem Beitrag kurz rein
mittlerweile ist es so jeder zweite
Patient der zu mir in die Apotheke kommt
hat irgendein Medikament auf dem Rezept
was nicht lieferbar ist schwer lieferbar
oder sogar gar nicht lieferbar sei es
nur ein Paracetamol Ibuprofen Säfte für
die Kleinsten in unserem Lande eine
Mutter lieben mit im Notdienst steht und
ich kann hier keine Paracetamolzäpfchen
geben und das Kind hat wo es Fieber ist
einfach dramatisch und ich frage mich
wirklich wo wir mit diesem Land noch hin
wollen wenn wir solche Banalitäten die
einfach vor 15 Jahren selbstverständlich
waren mittlerweile nicht mehr liefern
können
das also Frau jung die uns auch gestern
geschildert hat wie Menschen in die
Apotheke kommen mit Tränen in den
augenhilfe brauchen und sie sie abweisen
muss und wir haben dafür ganz viele
Zuschriften bekommen von Menschen die
sagten es geht uns ganz genauso und zwar
quer durch Deutschland schauen wir
einmal rein was wir für Zuschriften
bekommen haben über Twitter über
Facebook haben die an E-Mails haben wir
bekommen hier zum Beispiel hat uns Roman
Tages geschrieben versuch mal in der
Apotheke Pantoprazol zu bekommen das ist
ein Magenmittel Hersteller ist ihm egal
man bekommt es einfach nicht einfach
einfachste Mitte Magenmittel
Fiebermittel für Kinder das also die
Situation Frau Hermann aber sag das über
Deutschland aus das ist ein Fehler
gewesen ist wesentliche Sachen des
Alltags in auszulagern in der Produktion
ich habe vor zehn Jahren ungefähr Mattia
Kardashian Zentralindien bereist und hat
dort eben auch Fabriken besucht in den
z.B Medikamente für Europa hergestellt
werden auch die chemische Industrie die
Vorprodukte Balance Test zum Beispiel
das sieht man in welchen Bereichen
Europa hat überall schon in Indien z.B
auch in anderen Ländern produzieren
lassen damit konnte man hier die die
Reise künstlich niedrig halten denn hier
wäre es ja zu teuer gewesen dass du zu
produzieren das Problem ist ja immer
teurer wird jetzt natürlich wird es
jetzt immer teurer weil mehr Nachfrage
da ist 4 Milliarden Menschen in Asien
und drumrum sind jetzt auch alle auf dem
Markt und bei denen wächst die Kaufkraft
deutlich besser als bei uns im
Verhältnis gesehen und das bedeutet auch
dass die sich jetzt Medikamente leisten
können die sich vorher nicht leisten
konnten ich habe ihn dir noch gesehen
wieder Apotheker Dreier aus der Folie
drückt und sagt du brauchst nur drei
nimm diese drei ich behalte die sieben
und gebe anderen also das ist eine
andere Nummer und wir werden das sind
ganz vielen Bereichen noch feststellen
wir haben auch eben wesentliche Bereiche
ausgelagert wo man im Alltag eben merkt
dass man das braucht wir haben auch bei
Lebensmitteln viel importiert und nicht
so viel selber hergestellt oder
produziert manches können wir ja auch
nicht produzieren die erst Banane wird
es nicht geben also
wir verlieren aber jetzt noch mehr
Produktion wir sind schon mittendrin ja
ihren Themen ganz klar das hat ganz
viele Branchen treffen Ihre Kamera ihr
Thema ihre Zeit ja also meine große
Sorge ist das ist eben nicht spricht
jetzt noch eine kleine große Gase und
strompreisbremse zu machen sondern die
Unternehmen in Deutschland sind massiv
verunsichert Investoren machen
inzwischen einen Bogen um Deutschland
wir haben einen stillen Schwund so eine
ich das von Firmen die nicht insolvent
gehen sondern Firmen die einfach zum
Jahresende oder zu Ostern zu machen die
inzwischen alles abmelden wir werden die
Statistiken dann spätestens Ostern
auswerten können von der Industrie und
Handelskammer von der Handwerkskammer
auch von den Gewerbeämtern in den
Städten und Kommunen und werden sehen
das ganz viele Firmen zugemacht haben im
Osten vielleicht mehr prozentual gesehen
weil bei uns nach der Wende die meisten
Leute gegründet haben da waren die
zwischen 30 und 45 sind alle im
Rentenalter oder kurz davor wollen die
Firma übergeben und keiner traut sich
bei diesen unsicheren Bedingungen eine
Firma zu kaufen oder neu aufzumachen das
Problem ist ja nicht dass wir dann bis
Ostern vielleicht ohne Blackout
durchkommen sondern das Problem ist das
auf Jahre hinaus nicht klar ist wie die
Wirtschaft in diesem Land kalkulieren
muss mit welchen Rahmenbedingungen sie
fertig werden muss wie die Preise sich
entwickeln weil nämlich die Regierung
nicht Unterlage ist eine vier oder fünf
einfaches Sicherheit wenigstens mal zu
projizieren das ist alles nur auf Sicht
fahren kein Unternehmer der ernsthaft in
der Industrie beschäftigt oder
Beschäftigte hat und Firma hat kann sich
das leisten mehrere Jahre auf sich zu
fahren das geht einfach nicht und
deswegen haben wir wahrscheinlich
Insolvenzen im Osten zwischen 15 und 20
Prozent im Westen vielleicht dann zehn
Prozent und wir werden auch den
stillenschwund noch haben also
mindestens ein Drittel der Firmen wird
dicht machen was ist das Kernproblem
Frau Herrmann ist es die Energie das
ändert die Energie ist das kein Problem
bei den Faktoren die so am wenigsten
beschäftigt einschätzen können also
jetzt haben wir bei Öl aber bei Gas und
so ein bisschen was gemacht bei Strom
aber nicht genug nicht ausreichend da
muss man eigentlich alles anschalten was
Strom produziert und den merken sie
signalisieren Deutschland wird die
nächsten Jahre immer Strom haben bei uns
gibt's keine Blackouts das wäre das
erste Markt Signal das zweite maximal
wir haben auch spätestens ab Januar
Februar brauchen wenn diese ähm Öl aus
Russland nicht mehr kommen trifft den
Osten wieder doppelt hat da geht's um
Diesel und Benzinpreise jetzt ist gerade
mal die Inflation wegen runtergegangen
ja das waren eben die nachgegebenen
Preis ein bisschen alles eingepreist
dann ist vielleicht noch der Transport
im Container Übersee billiger geworden
oder irgendwas anderes und dann wirkt
das so als ob die Inflation runtergeht
wie geht wieder hoch und zwar in dem
Moment wo diese und Benzin wieder teurer
werden vor allen Dingen Diesel weil
alles was der Mensch einkaufen will wird
meistens dahin geschleppt wo es einkauft
sie waren selbst im Bundestag lange was
würden Sie Kanzler Scholz jetzt raten
konkrete Maßnahmen was muss jetzt
umgesetzt werden also er muss mindestens
bis zum Jahresende geklärt haben egal ob
die Grünen da wie Rumpelstilzchen um das
Feuer springen oder nicht dass wir
Stromproduktion brauchen über mehrere
Jahre hinweg die verlässlich und günstig
ist sie muss bezahlbar sein da sind wir
bei Atom es gibt keinen Weg dran vorbei
dann müssen die Grünen eben in Sachen
Apfel beißen und wenn sie das nicht
machen wollen dann musste er Scholz
überlegen ob er dann eben mit der CDU
das zusammen macht die müssen allerdings
auch wieder eine Kehrtwende von der
Kehrtwende machen also die Wände hält
sie haben inzwischen schon
Schraubgewinde
es geht kein Weg dran vorbei die
Realität ist das ist kein Industrieland
gibt das gut funktioniert indem es kein
bezahlbaren und stetig verschiedenen
Strom gibt das ist pillepalle die
Regierung möchte ja alles auf Strom
umbauen in Verkehr und was nicht alles
ja da brauchen wir erst recht noch mehr
Strom und eh die anderen Investitionen
alle greifen sind wir im Jahr 2027 wir
müssen jetzt signalisieren den
heimischen Unternehmern und den
ausländischen Investoren in Deutschland
probt da läuft es weiter die deutschen
Großkonzerne fragraschke die sitzen dann
quasi jetzt schon auf gepacktem Koffern
was passiert spielen wir das Szenario
mal weiter wenn
ich immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
also ich stimme der Analyse zu das ist
eine sehr schwierige Lage ist ich denke
das ist auch gerade also klein und
mittelständische Betriebe also ich denke
da eher erstmal an den Bäcker der ist
einfach nicht mehr schafft wegen der
Energiekosten die sind schon drin das
ist aber auch ein riesen Problem
soziales ich glaube was man was man
vielleicht aus dieser ganzen Sache
lernen kann die hat ja zwei Aspekte es
ist immer glaube ich sehr schlecht wenn
Ideologie zu sehr vor die Klammer
gezogen wird in den 90er Jahren wurde
uns ja von allen top Ökonomen erzählt
also die Globalisierung ist eine ganz
tolle Sache das wurde dann als
kampfargument gegen die gegen die
Gewerkschaften und die Arbeitnehmer
verwendet die Löhne sein hier zu hoch
und und und Arbeitnehmerrechte überhaupt
ganz was schlechtes und man würde dann
also quasi zur Strafe lieber im Ausland
produzieren und Leute also Konzerne wie
VW gingen dann erst nach Tschechien und
so und inzwischen hängen sie in China in
einer ganz komplizierten Situationen das
politische System dann doch nicht so
erfreulich
also insofern ja also es war damals hat
man uns vorausgesagt also bei diesen
Löwen wird die gesamte deutsche
Wirtschaft Deutschland verlassen und das
hat sie nicht getan weil es natürlich
doch viele nahbeziehungen und viele
Vorteile sozusagen damals zumindest noch
gegeben hat man muss gucken wie das
jetzt ist mit dem Bildungssystem und so
das sind auch Faktoren
können die Leute lesen und schreiben und
können Sie ihm geben gegebenenfalls das
lernen was sie in der Ausbildung oder in
dem Fachstudium lernen müssen also da
war Ideologie nicht so gut denn jetzt
hätten wir die Sachen lieber gerne etwas
näher bei uns weil wir sehen was für
Stress Globalisierung reinbringt und was
für schwierige politische Fragen sei es
Russland sei es China ist eben die
Energie Frage also jetzt im Namen der
Energiewende und überhaupt der
ökologischen Transformation Gesellschaft
das ist ja der neueste Hit also alles
vor die Klammer zu ziehen und zu sagen
dem ordnen wir alles unter
wirtschaftliche Fragen was ich nicht
also Fragen der Selbstbestimmung der
Bürger und so da sind wir ja auf dem
besten Weg und da würde ich auch wieder
sagen vorsicht also natürlich also es
gab in meiner Generation hat man sehr
gelernt dass Atomkraft sehr sehr
gefährlich ist und das Restrisiko und
man soll das alles also nach Kräften
vermeiden aber letzten Endes haben wir
in Deutschland auf einem hohen
technischen Niveau Atomkraftwerke gehabt
wir haben auch keine schlimmen
Katastrophen stehen jetzt trotzdem nicht
gut also da müsste die FDP nicht richtig
Druck machen
sie versucht es ja bei verschiedenen
Themen die FDP das finde ich eigentlich
immer ganz tapfer das ist war in der
Opposition also als praktisch einzige
Oppositionsparteien nicht
in der Regierung ist es irgendwie auch
aber
es wird angedroht sag ich mal jetzt
außer sich eines Unternehmens
Erbschaftssteuer das kann bei
Unternehmen nachfolgenden Problemen sein
wir haben höhere Steuern Aussicht die
werden es durch Inflation sowieso schon
über die Mehrwertsteuer ganz andere
eingenommen aber auch höhere Steuern
werden in Aussicht gestellt 2024 kommen
noch mal neue Bewertungen rein also
eigentlich weiße Unternehmer die
nächsten Jahre werden alle brutal und
jetzt komme ich mal zu einem guten
Mittelständler mit einer guten Marke
wenn die Marke weltweiten Markt hat und
die Leute wissen das ist eine gute Marke
dann muss der nicht in Deutschland
produzieren er macht das gerne weil er
eben seine Heimat liebt und weil er da
ansässig ist aber er muss es nicht und
wenn einfach zu viele Daumenschrauben
gleichzeitig angezogen werden dann
platzt auch den patriotischsten
Unternehmer irgendwann mal ertragen
[Gelächter]
wir laufen im Ziel Konflikte rein nein
die die sich weder die Öffentlichkeit
also in Form der Medien noch die
Politiker eingestehen wir können nicht
als größtes Exportland also als Land mit
dem höchsten Exportanteil in Europa nur
mit Ländern handeln die unsere
europäischen Werte teilen nur mit den
Wirtschaft treiben wir können natürlich
nur mit den Wirtschaft treiben ja dann
verschwindet ein großer großer Teil
unserer Industrie und nicht nur unsere
Industrie vor allem auch im Mittelstand
auch in Afrika viele Länder ich meine
alleine wo beziehen wir wo beziehen wir
das Lithium und und andere Rohstoffe für
unsere Elektroauto Batterien
jede Menge 2 Zielkonflikt wir können
nicht nur saubere Energien also nur aus
richtig sauberem grünen Verständnis ja
nur aus Wind und Sonne äh Strom gewinnen
und gleichzeitig eine hoch energetische
Volkswirtschaft betreiben zweiter
Zielkonflikt im Ergebnis stehen wir
heute da mit dem einen mit der höchsten
Anteile der Kohle Verstromung in ganz
Europa
Teil der politischen Landschaft der
absolut ideologisch vom Atom weg will
weil nur indem wir als ob wir eine heile
Welt schaffen indem wir Deutsche das
Atom vergessen wir sind in eine
Sackgasse ja überhaupt wir sind auf
einem Weg weg von der weg von der
Realität und weg vom Realismus werden
Sanktionen aussetzen und sie
währenddessen die Ukraine kaputt machen
lassen das ist
ich fordere ja nicht jetzt dass man sich
in dem Ziel Konflikt so oder so
entscheiden muss man kann ja auch auf
das alles verzichten wir können ja die
Sanktionen aufrecht dann wir brauchen
nicht nach China Autos zu verkaufen nur
fragen Sie dann die vw-arbeiter ob die
das Verkaufen und fragen Sie die in
Sachsen die Mittelständler die vor dem
Krieg wirklich teilweise 30 40 50% ihre
Umsätze mit Russland gemacht haben
fragen Sie die ja dann entscheidet man
sich ich ich sag nur mal aus den
Zielkonflikt erstmal bin in meinem Namen
nennen Frankreich Italien beispielsweise
die kaufen LG Flüssigkeit ist auch in
Russland na klar
kriegst und das finde ich auch
vollkommen richtig und klar also man
wird nicht alle Probleme der Welt und
nicht alle moralischen Fragen der Welt
lösen können über den deutschen
Außenhandel aber man muss ja irgendwo
mal anfangen und die Ukraine als
europäisches Problem und und als
europäische Katastrophe ist uns nun mal
sehr nach und dann muss man eben
irgendetwas tun ja auch gesagt man muss
mal irgendetwas entscheiden
ist also man hört so wahnsinnig
unterschiedliche Dinge übers Fracking
und Fracking ist zum Beispiel auch
fürchterlich geächtet ich glaube da
hätten wir durchaus vorkommen die wir
erschließen könnten und das ist eben
auch auf der Todesliste der Grünen als
gar nicht diskutabel und ich glaube
diese ganze Frage so der
technologieoffenheit also ist gut können
wir also was gibt's denn alles für
Möglichkeiten nicht also auch bei den
E-Autos jetzt die sind ja in der Öko
also in der herstellungsbilanz auch gar
nicht so die Batterien und die Batterien
sind ein riesiges Problem sowohl in der
Herstellung als auch in der Entsorgung
aber jetzt haben wir irgendwie
draufgesetzt jetzt muss es unbedingt und
nur das sein und das ist sehr deutsch
finde ich also dieses ganze oder gar
nicht frisst oder stirbt bleiben wir mal
beim LG Gas aus Russland
ja ich würde es holen es wird ja sowieso
nach Europa reingeholt jetzt würden auch
jetzt würde ich sagen es wird sowieso
nach Europa reingeholt es wird über
Portugal über Spanien über Frankreich
über Italien vor allen Dingen andere
auch also wird reingeholt die deutschen
machen jetzt noch besonders wir machen
es auf gar keinen Fall aber sind
eigentlich nicht im Mainstream der
Europäer wenn sich mal angucken wer
alles aus Russland Erdgas bezieht die
Geschichte wird dann jetzt zum ersten
ersten entschieden also ich glaube dass
die Sanktionen nicht bei weitem den
Erfolg gehabt haben den sie haben
sollten Sie haben zumindest eine
zweischneidige Wirkung also es gibt
einen rückwirker-effekt auf uns und wir
müssen entscheiden ob wir den aushalten
können oder nicht es gibt auch Dinge wo
man sagt oh ja ich bin tapfer dagegen
und dann merkst du es geht nicht das
hätte dann passieren sollen wie was
hätte passieren soll ich sagen was hätte
passieren müssen damit sie sagen die
Sanktion waren richtig es war gut dass
wir da ein Cut gemacht haben naja es
hätte passieren nicht passieren dürfen
dass wir uns selber so ins Knie schießen
sag mal so rum also ich hätte das
geklappt ne das hätte zum Beispiel
geklappt indem man nicht gleich am
Anfang rum triumphiert und sagt wir
werden hier gar nichts mehr von Russland
beziehen und dann groß einen aufmacht
die Sanktionen kamen Wesentlichen aus
den USA und die Briten haben das immer
sehr stark unterstützt die Deutschen
haben dann mitgemacht das war meine
Beobachtung der Diskussion ist ich finde
dass die Deutschen und die Europäer zu
wenig auf ihre eigenen Interessen
geguckt haben und ich glaube auch dass
es ein überzogen gewesen ist zu denken
dass der Russe dann irgendwann wieder in
Berlin steht aber sind ist die Ukraine
nicht europäische Interessen auf die wir
eben auch zu gucken haben das finde ich
schon also ich glaube ja nicht das
Putins Aggressionen sozusagen aufhören
würde wenn jetzt also es gibt ja auch
viele die sagen also einseitig also
keine soll einseitig verhandeln also
egal wie Erde ihr Land zusammen bombt
sie sollen jetzt mal wieder
Verhandlungen anbieten das sehe ich eben
nicht so sondern also der Krug in der
Ukraine wäre sofort zu Ende wenn die
Russen aufhören anzugreifen wenn die
Ukraine aufhören sich zu verteidigen ist
die Ukraine Weg so also insofern man
sieht da ein eine unglaubliches Unrecht
und und ein völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg und ich finde man kann das
schwer mit ansehen und wenn man
junge Menschen kennt aus der Ukraine die
ja auch in Europa sich frei bewegt haben
zum Beispiel als Erasmus-Studenten und
so und die eigentlich so stark
orientiert waren auf aus Mitgliedschaft
in der EU gut die NATO Mitgliedschaft
wünschen sich eigentlich alle aus
europäischen Staaten weil sie nämlich
Russland als Nachbarn kennen und
insofern so froh waren als sie aus der
Sowjetunion selbst entscheiden dürfen zu
welchem Bundes
kann man eigentlich nur unterstützen und
insofern würde ich an dem Punkt sagen
das ist das ist sie haben lange in
Russlands gelebt glauben Sie dass man
mit diesem Putin irgendwie verhandeln
kann glauben Sie im Moment im Moment
sicher nicht ich würde aber davor waren
ich komme auf das Thema zurück worüber
wir reden D und die Industrialisierung
weltweite Energie und Wirtschaftskrise
ich glaube wir sollten Russlands Rolle
den Rolle des russischen Kriegs in der
Ukraine
vor dem Hintergrund dieser ganzen
Phänomene nicht überbewerben das war
sicher der Einstieg der Anlass ja aber
die Verteuerung unserer Energie
Ressourcen hat lange vor diesem Krieg
eingesetzt die Abhängigkeit mit Nord
Stream 2 die Abhängigkeit von russischen
Gas wäre er erst mit Nord Stream 2 mit
110 Milliarden Kubikmetern im Jahr sehr
groß geworden mit den 55 Milliarden das
ging ja noch ähm die Abhängigkeit war
natürlich insofern leichtfertig als dass
wir gleichzeitig über Jahre hinweg auf
einen System und Werte Wettbewerb mit
den Russen auch wieder auf den
geostrategische Konkurrenz gesetzt haben
also da haben wir uns schon offen
gefährliches
insofern bin ich fast glücklich dass wir
jetzt in der Situation sind wo auch die
marktwirtschaftlichen Kräfte dafür
sorgen müssen dass wir auch unsere
Energie Ressourcen neu finden vor allem
unser Problem ist zum Beispiel wenn wir
über den Strom reden das hat nichts mit
Russland zu den die Atom Diskussion ja
die Energiewende hat nichts mit Russland
Suchen von 2011 also wir sollten hier
schon die Rolle des Ukraine Kriegs
wahrnehmen und angemessen auch
betrachten aber eben nicht putin ist
nicht an alle Misere Schuld nicht die
Ausrede für eine missglückte
Energiewende das ist genau der Punkt
was miteinander zu tun ne die
Atomkraftwerke und Putin denn jetzt kann
man die beiden Energie Themen ja nicht
mehr voneinander trennen aber das wäre
ja vorher war das ja auch nur für
Fiktion das war immer Frau Merkel hat
unter der Hand ohne es offen zu sagen
der zu der Energiewende genickt weil sie
davon ausgegangen ist wir können das
relativ CO2
nicht nicht vor weniger belastete
relativ unbelastete CO2 unbelastete Gas
aus einsetzen als Brückentechnologie bis
dann irgendwann in der zweiten
Jahrhundert helfen oder so Sonne und und
man kann es in einem Satz zusammenfassen
die Sanktionen könnte man sich leisten
wenn man begreift dass man dann nicht
mehr mit dem Gas die Schwankungsreserve
für Wind und Sonne machen und dass man
die Atomkraftwerke braucht dann könnte
man sich dann könnte man ja die muss man
sich leisten können und dann könnten wir
uns diese Moral leisten aber wenn die
Atomkraftwerke eben zugemacht werden und
nicht diese Ausgleich sozusagen bei den
schwankungsenergien von Sonne und Wind
gemacht werden und wir das Gas dafür
nicht haben dann haben wir einen
gravierendes Problem das heißt man muss
schon für die anderen mitdenken und für
80 Millionen ein bisschen Empathie haben
bevor man sich in die brustwirft oder
wir fragen uns schon alle in was für ein
Winter wieder Steuern nichts mehr
leisten können sich auf jeden Fall die
Briten einen Artikel hat uns aufhorchen
lassen essen oder heizen für dieser
Entscheidung laut falls stehen viele
Menschen jetzt auf der Insel in
Großbritannien in der Entwicklung mein
Kollege ist hier bei uns wieder du hast
lange in Großbritannien gelebt dass
viele Verbindungen noch weiter dahinter
ist auch in diesem Thema noch mal vier
recherchiert Schilder uns einmal wie
dramatisch ist dort die Lage und wir
wollen hier auch die Frage aufwerfen ist
das ein Szenario das auch bei uns
möglich wäre deine Kamera dein Thema
vielen Dank ja heating or eating so
nennen die das in Großbritannien essen
oder heizen das ist die Frage viele
Haushalte fast 20 Prozent müssen Sie
sich jetzt stellen denn Sie können es
sich nicht mehr leisten beides zu machen
eine Energierechnung eine Gasrechnung
ist für den Durchschnittshaushalt da
jetzt 2500 Pfund das sind fast 3000 €,
die food banks die sogenannten das ist
das was bei uns die Tafeln sind sagen
noch nie seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sind
so viele Leute in der Schlange man kommt
nicht mehr hinterher England wird zum
kranken Mann Europas und die können die
Rückschritte die sie durch den brexit
erlebt haben jetzt nicht mehr einholen
und ich glaube auch Deutschland läuft
Gefahr in diese Richtung zu gehen wenn
wir nicht ganz schnell wach werden das
ist hier in der Runde schon angeklungen
und wenn wir nicht das was uns immer
gedient hat und was ich bewährt hat in
unserem Land nämlich die Industrie
festhalten und weiter fördern
das klingt unvorstellbar brutal dass es
Menschen gibt die von dieser
Entscheidung stehen im du hast es gerade
schon so ein bisschen angedeutet lass
uns einmal tiefer reingehen glaubst du
da ist Großbritannien durch den brexit
und durch viele andere Sachen ein
Sonderfall beschreib uns einmal genauer
warum du glaubst dass dieses Szenario
auch Deutschland zumindest drohen könnte
also um deine erste Frage zu beantworten
es ist ein Sonderfall bei England die
ein extrem tertiären Sektor hat heißt
Dienstleistungen Versicherung Anwälte
Rückversicherung genau
das heißt sie sind ihre abhängig vom
globalen Markt und wenn in der Welt
Sachen passieren die Instabilität
bedeuten dann wackelt England die immer
mit was sie nicht mehr haben ist
Textilindustrie Schwerindustrie
Eisenindustrie Stahlindustrie alles was
hier in Deutschland zum Teil zumindest
noch da ist Bergbau gibt es auch nicht
mehr in England die Sachen also die man
anfassen kann Autos das gibt's ja nicht
mehr es ist nicht mehr griffig und wir
in Deutschland haben ein größeren Anteil
als die Briten an diesen Industrien an
der Industrie und ich glaube dass das
der Unterschied ist der uns im Moment
wie so ein Puffer noch schützt aber das
ist eben vergänglich ich glaube das
trifft bei Ihnen auch einen wunden Punkt
gearbeitet und kenne mich dann ein
bisschen aus war da in solchen
Diskussionsrunden und mit dabei auf der
Insel und natürlich haben die nach
Lehman Brothers vor zwölf Jahren
begriffen dass sie wieder ein bisschen
retouring machen müssen wieder ein
bisschen Industrie Wertschöpfungsketten
wieder schließen auf der Insel begriffen
haben sie die Umsetzung war kompliziert
das zeigt mir eins wenn du es mal
verloren hast ist es weg du kriegst das
nicht so schnell wieder auf die Beine
gestellt das verflochtene System von
Handwerk von freiberufen und von
produzierten Gewerbe das ist ein
Meisterwerk und das ist wie ein Urwerk
da kannst du nicht ein Rädchen
rausnehmen er spielt keine Rolle mach
mal was anderes nee dann läuft das Ding
nicht mehr und das ist glaube ich der
entscheidende Punkt also die oft bei den
Franzosen mit ihrer Staatswirtschaft man
kann in den anderen Ländern gucken was
passiert wenn du nicht eben so einen
starken Mittelstand hast du am Dreieck
mit dem Handwerk und den freien Berufen
eine stabile Einheit bildet und die in
der Lage sind mehr zu exportieren als
Großbritannien und Frankreich zusammen
Politiker der sagt ja einfach Nein dann
holen das ist alles eben nach der Krise
wieder nein also Betriebe die jetzt zu
machen
gehen auch so zu machen verlagern ihren
Standort die machen eine Beerdigung
zweiter Klasse naja wir machen jetzt
erstmal zu ne wie ist der Minister
vorgeschlagen hat in seiner Weisheit und
das heißt dann im Prinzip bei also ich
Aluminiumproduktion die wird dann eben
in Deutschland nicht mehr geben wenn du
auf dem Weltmarkt zweieinhalb bis 3000
Euro pro Tonne bezahlst und du
produzierst für 7 bis 8000 € wegen
Energiekosten was das eben du kannst
nicht wirtschaftliche Wirtschaft nicht
weiterführen das wissen wir als alte der
Bürger ganz genau das ist nicht klappt
es zu viel Schwarzmalerei na ja also ich
glaube es ist schon auch in Deutschland
so ich habe jetzt die letzte Umfrage
nicht ganz genau im Kopf aber das bis zu
50% der Leute sagen sie geben praktisch
ihr ganzes verfügbares Einkommen im
Moment aus für die Leute Kosten also für
Essen und und heißen und und was eben
sonst noch so anfällt das ist ja auch
schon ganz schön hart und ich glaube
diese ganze Hand in den Mund alles ja
und dass ich glaube das verunsichert
Menschen auch sehr also gerade die
Deutschen ein Prinzip schon auch zur
Vorsicht und sparen eigentlich auch in
Spanien ganz gerne und ob man das fand
man immer nicht so klug weil man sagt
die geht auch an die Börse und so weiter
aber es ist jetzt eben ganz schwierig
also auch nur das beruhigende das
beruhigende sparen zu machen und das
führt natürlich nicht zu einer zu einer
wahnsinnig guten Stimmung und deswegen
ist die Frage schon was kann man gegen
die Inflation machen die ja die Preise
so wahnsinnig treibt und das ist eben
das Teufels die Regierung macht jetzt
ein milliardenschweres Hilfsprogramm
nach dem anderen sie kriegt dafür wenig
Zuneigung vom Bürger weil man nämlich im
Einzelnen gar nicht durchschaut was
kommt mir davon jetzt eigentlich kommt
mir davon eigentlich irgendwas zu Gute
was hilft es eigentlich ähm aber diese
aber diese riesige ständig steigende
staatsverschuldigung ich habe sehr große
Bundeshaushalt ever
nicht also die die treibt natürlich auch
die Inflation die wahnsinnig irgendwann
müssen die Gewerkschaften nachziehen und
sagen wir brauchen halt entsprechende
Lohnabschlüsse und ich meine jetzt was
hatten wir beide oder was 8%, das ist ja
schon sehr viel also wir haben den
letzten Jahren nie gehabt aber es ist
immer noch weg sofort an der
Supermarktkasse und das ist natürlich
das ist natürlich Wahnsinn schlimm
er hat gesagt das wird ein Winter der
Armut werden nicht hier im Land Herr da
kommen wir durch diese Krise ist es
Schwarzmalerei was glauben Sie nein ist
das nicht ich glaube das große Problem
ist dass unsere Politik und auch unsere
Diskussion sich eigentlich immer darum
drehen wie können wir den Status Quo in
irgendeiner Form halten gewährleisten
also ich will keine Werbung habe ich
habe ja vor zwei Wochen ein Buch
veröffentlicht das heißt das unheimliche
jahrhundert und das dreht sich genau
darum dass wir in eine Epoche
hineinlaufen in der vor allem erst
einmal der Status Quo nicht zu halten
sein wird
ehrlich machen man muss sich irgendwann
mal schauen wir müssen den Gürtel enger
schneiden vergessen sie mal 23 Mal im
Januar und ja
was anderes Stichwort Großbritannien ist
interessant
Großbritannien war das erste
Industrieland Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts
Großbritannien hat ein Vorlauf von
ungefähr 100 Jahren ja vor uns und
Industrien ja sind wir haben historische
Lebenszyklen ähm Metall etc das was in
Großbritannien jetzt geschieht muss uns
dazu veranlassen daraus zu lernen was
ganz wichtig Handwerk Mittelstand ja die
wir werden die Kfz-Industrie in dem
Ausmaß nicht halten können weil die
künftigen Autos wenn es elektroautos
werden die werden billiger und mit viel
weniger Teilen mit viel weniger Menschen
also ganz ganz wenn dieser ganze Zweig
wegbricht wir werden uns damit
auseinandersetzen müssen dass die
Kfz-Industrie die Chemieindustrie die
Metallindustrie zumindest stark
dezimiert wird unser großes Pfund ist
der Mittelstand und wenn wir den
Mittelstand jetzt steuerlich nicht
stützen aber den Mittelstand nicht durch
massive Bildung und das dass wir auch
das Handwerk wieder zum Glück gibt's ja
jetzt Initiativen wo man sagt Leute geht
nicht alle auf die Uni lernten Handwerk
ja man kann als Handwerk inzwischen hat
man wesentlich bessere Lebensaussichten
also Einkommensaussichten als in vielen
akademischen Fächern ja darauf das ist
die Chance und das meine ich mit von
England lernen nicht fest überlegen
jetzt wie können wir vermeiden dass
unsere alten Industrie sterben das
können wir nicht vermeiden ja aber wie
wo wir jetzt sehen England wie können
wir besser darauf reagieren und wir
haben glaube ich rückläufiges Startup
Zahlen in den vergangen ja da muss man
sich dann auch noch mal fragen also wie
schwer machen wir das Menschen
eigentlich in den Zeiten ist es auch
schwer ne das kommt natürlich dazu also
klar das ist der das ist der
corona-effekt aber es war glaube ich
auch vorher schon so und es ist einfach
die Frage wie viel Bürokratie erfordert
sozusagen die Umsetzung einer einer
neuen Idee Zurückhaltung könnte es auch
beim Start gehen wenn man seit 2010 oder
12 40 % Zuwachs bei den Bundesbehörden
und bei der
Bundesregierung das sind schon nicht
also da würde ich sagen ein bisschen
Zurückhaltung auch nicht verkehrt und
mir fehlt eben auch die
Bildungsoffensive das eine ist gerne ins
Handwerk gehen das andere ist studiert
aber studiert doch nicht alle
Politikwissenschaft also so
ist
wo ist die Bildungsoffensive zum
Beispiel genau für den Energiebereich da
ist so viel auch da sind so viele Fragen
übrigens
genau studiert hat
auf einmal ganz kurz durch hier bei 8:15
Uhr sind wir gleich wieder zurück
schauen weiterhin in die Zukunft es wird
bleiben Sie gerne bei uns
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht holen hier ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Staaten wenn die
alle wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig
in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos verkaufen
das funktioniert nicht dann ist alles
essen als Freiheit würde ich sagen das
muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über dem Gerät
[Musik]
oh Gott
wir haben tatsächlich nur ein
Politikwissenschaft
damit sie das auch wissen ich habe
versprochen wir werfen einen Blick in
die Zukunft ja ich viele Unternehmen
verzweifeln am Fachkräftemangel viele
fragen sich wo bekommen wir mehr
Arbeitskräfte her aber gleichzeitig
wollen wir auch einen größeren Blick in
die Zukunft werfen und Herr Faßbender
sind wir bei ihrem Thema denn sie sie
sagen da wird sich einiges verändern und
zwar ein ganz Europa 8 Milliarden
beträgt die Menschheit seit November
2022 der 8 Mensch wurde wurde geboren
wenn man das vergleicht mit den 50er
Jahren das sind mehr als doppelt so
viele und es gibt jetzt zu diesem Thema
nicht nur den allgemeinen
Bevölkerungszuwachs weltweit der ja seit
den 90er Jahren schon gebremst wird ja
die zugangsraten gehen zurück es wird
wahrscheinlich auf 10 10,5 Milliarden
Ende des Jahrhunderts hinauslaufen aber
es gibt ein singuläres Phänomen in
diesem Jahrhundert und das ist das der
allergrößte Teil des bevölkers zu ist es
eben zwar im 21 Jahrhundert in subsahara
Afrika also in Afrika südlich der Sahara
stattfinden wird dort verdoppelt sich
die Bevölkerung von 2020 bis 2050 um gut
eine Milliarde und verdoppelt sich ein
weiteres Mal in der zweiten Jahrhundert
Hälfte also bis zum Jahr 2100 auf dann 4
Milliarden im 22 jahrhundert wird
irgendwann zuerst jeder dritte und dann
jeder zweite Mensch südlich der Sahara
geboren seit drei Viertel aller
Neugeborenen in diesem Jahrhundert
kommen südlich der Sahara zur Welt und
gleichzeitig und das ist der zweite
singen und das zweite singuläre Phänomen
laufen wir mit der Erderwärmung in eine
Situation hinein in der vor allem die
tropischen Gebiete also die Gebiete
zwischen den Wendekreisen fünf Grad
nördliche fünf Grad südliche breit und
da liegen 85 % der afrikanischen
Landmasse in denen die Nahrungsmittel
und die Wasser die Situation der
Nahrungsmittelversorgung und
Wasserversorgung doch in diesen Tropen
auch noch in Südamerika massiv
beeinträchtigt werden wird wir werden
aus diesen Gründen einem enormen
Wanderungsdruck aus Afrika Richtung es
geht nur Richtung Norden ja ausgesetzt
sein und unsere Politik und im weitesten
Sinne auch die auch die Wissenschaft die
öffentliche Diskussion nimmt diese
singulären Veränderungen überhaupt noch
nicht zu Kenntnis was werden diese
Veränderungen bewirken zeichnen Sie uns
das einmal auf wir haben zurzeit
praktisch oder sehr wenig Migration
Zuwanderung aus Gebieten südlich der
Sahara also die Migration über die wir
heute reden das ist im Wesentlichen
Nordafrika das ist im wesentlichen in
der Nahe Osten also der arabische Raum
ja Afghanistan Iran südlich der Sahara
die die das sind 10 20 Prozent der
Migranten ja wir reden also ich rede
hier also praktisch von wesentlich von
der zweiten Jahrhundert Hälfte aber das
beginnt natürlich schon in den 30er 40er
Jahren wenn die Situation der
Nahrungsmittel Versorgung durch die
zunehmen in der Erwärmung so steigen
wird denn wir wir müssen davon ausgehen
dass wir nicht nur die 1,5 Grad nicht
schaffen wir werden auch die zwei Grad
nicht schaffen ja also wir müssen es
dann nackt und ehrlich machen das ist
der erste Fehler den wir begehen und wir
müssen uns darauf einstellen dass wir
einfach aus diesen hinzukommenden
Milliarden hunderten Millionen ja einen
Migrationsdruck haben den wir in
Westeuropa nicht standhalten können ja
wenn nicht standhalten werden das
bedeutet unsere Gesellschaft wird erst
recht wenn nach der Jahrhundertmitte die
geburtenstarken Jahr den Gedanken
gänzlich weggestorben sind unsere
Gesellschaft wird in der zweiten
Jahrhundert Hälfte und das ist 30 Jahre
hin ja das ist nicht viel das wird
vollkommen anders aussehen wird
ökonomisch anders strukturiert sein und
es ist höchste Zeit ob man das will oder
nicht sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
dass man die Dinge einfach mal aufs Tape
bringt und das meinte ich mit ihm wir
gehen immer noch davon aus irgendwie
wird der Status Quo auch noch in diesem
Jahrhundert so sein wie wir ihn aus den
letzten 50 Jahren kennen
Riesenfehler
das wäre natürlich ganz vielen Menschen
auch einfach lieb Frau Hermel da sind
wir dieser Entwicklung völlig machtlos
ausgeliefert wir verdrängen das einfach
ich habe zwei 15 auch mal ein Buch
geschrieben die Zukunft wird anders
klingt nach machtlos ausgeliefert werden
ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen was
ich hier vortragen finde das auch
richtig dass wir es aussprechen und die
Frage steht im Raum ergibt man sich
jetzt einfach oder überlegt man ob
bisherige Handlungen nicht gewirkt haben
also ich habe z.B im Bundeshaushalt bei
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit war ich
jahrelang mit beschäftigt meiner Meinung
nach festgestellt dass da sehr viel Geld
für wenig Effekt ausgegeben wird das
hatte sozusagen wenig Effekt im Sinne
was erreicht werden soll nämlich das
andere länderwirtschaftlich vorankommen
und ihre Bevölkerung versorgen können
weil die hohe Geburtenrate mitunter auch
historisch damit was zu tun hat dass die
Eltern dann irgendjemanden brauchen der
sie versorgt und nicht alle Kinder
durchkommen bis zum Erwachsenenalter
meiner Meinung nach wäre es zum Beispiel
klug wenn die Europäer endlich mal
verstanden haben dass sie sozusagen ein
bisschen für Afrika mit zuständig sind
was ich glaube dass das stimmt die
Amerikaner haben da Südamerika also in
der Entwicklungshilfe ja woanders ich
würde sagen eine wirtschaftlich
Zusammenarbeit die darauf beruht dass
ich Partnerländer bilden und dass man
versucht eine Industrialisierung in
diesen Ländern zu erreichen damit die
ihre Bevölkerung organisieren kann und
versorgen kann und da im Gegenzug zu
verhandeln dass man zum Beispiel auf
eine zwei kindpolitik oder sowas
umschwenkt um die ganz große Spitze in
der zweiten Jahrhundert Hälfte ein
bisschen abzuflachen ich halte das für
schlau aber dann müssten wir uns
wirklich auch so einigen da müsst nicht
Europa und afrikanischen Tisch setzen
und das klären haben wir in den letzten
50 Jahren alles falsch gemacht Frau
Gaschke ist unsere Entwicklungspolitik
im Prinzip geschaltet unseren
Entwicklungshilfe ja ich glaube es gibt
von von Peters Luder direkt den Satz die
einzige Katastrophe die jeder versteht
ist die Katastrophe die keiner überlebt
und wir zeigen einfach das ist aber
glaube ich auch normal menschlich dazu
also etwas fernliegendere Probleme zu
verdrängen ja auch wichtig ist fürs
Überleben fürs leben und überleben weil
wenn ich sozusagen jetzt Szenario höre
dann ist das ja Apokalypse entfernen
30 Jahren also sozusagen das natürlich
also sozusagen man kann mal bei der
Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit anfangen ich
glaube alles was da im Moment zum
Fenster rausgeschmissen wird ist
vollkommen sinnlose Projekte also die
Demokratisierung der afghanischen
Gesellschaft jetzt von Dubai aus mit
irgendwelchen
medienprogramm
aber das ist natürlich nicht unendlich
viel Geld es ist einfach nur es ist
industriellen Partner genau also
insofern das das scheint mir plausibel
zu sein aber trotzdem auch wenn man HCR
hört wir werden einen wahnsinnigen
Migrationsdruck kriegen und zwar genau
ja auch wegen der Klima Probleme wenn
wir die Industrialisierung vorantreiben
mit diesen Menschenmassen dann treiben
wir natürlich wiederum darf
zu dem Thema wenn wir die Hälfte des
Geldes ausgeben würden was wir ausgeben
wollen so CO2 Vermeidung und geben es
diesen Ländern damit die anders anfangen
in der Energieproduktion haben wir mehr
CO2 eingespart als wir Deutschen noch
rausquetschen können also ja
das ist kolonialistisch weil wir denen
dann ja nicht erlauben sich so zu
entwickeln wie wir es gemacht wenn man
sich vereinbarten Verträge schließt ist
das nicht aber dann kommen die und sagen
hey wieso jetzt habt ihr 60 Jahre lang
die wollten gerne dass die
industrialisierten Länder ihn dabei
helfen das ist ein Wunsch in unserem
industrialisierten Luxusleben und sagen
ja das ist alles und jetzt haben wir uns
der Messias Greta Thunberg wer auch
immer erleuchtet und jetzt haben wir
verstanden das ist falsch und deswegen
ihr armen Afrikaner so zu Hause bitte
lasst es jetzt und wir bezahlen eine
Welt Gedanke den die Afrikaner auch aber
man muss kontrolliert also wenn wenn
dann die geldstiftung das versucht also
das andere
Methoden klar aber sozusagen damit auch
Problem sozusagen keine Ahnung
in Thailand oder anderen
das hat natürlich damit zu tun dass wir
in Asien seit 40 50 Jahren eine
ökonomisches wachstumszenario haben
real,-
weniger als 2% zur gesamten
Weltwirtschaft Welt Wertschöpfung ja das
sind extrem geringe Zahlen der die
gesamte Stromverbrauch
energieverbrauchen als Stromverbrauch in
Afrika ist geringer als der von Algerien
oder von Spanien ja da ist in Afrika ist
insofern ein faszinierendes Szenario
weil sie gleichzeitig archaische
Zustände und enormen Fortschritt enorme
Entwicklung haben und ich möchte mir
ganz klar für mich ist das kein
apokalyptisches Szenario wir werden eine
gemeinsame Zukunft als Europäer und
Afrikaner haben die wir noch nie so
gehabt haben das ist doch kein keine
Apokalypse
ja das ist das Problem
das Entscheidende ist das es geht ja
auch unsere Kinder
Millionen Flüchtlingen darüber dass wir
sie in diese Gesellschaft nicht perfekt
integriert kriegen und und wir werden
wir werden uns von den Vorstellungen
dieser Gesellschaft auch entfernen
müssen und das glaube ich jede neue
Generation die jetzt da hineinwächst die
wächst ja schon in eine andere Welt
hinein das sind ja die Generationen die
jetzt richtig aus dem 20 Jahrhundert
kommen die sagen nein das ist für mich
ein apokalyptischer Gedanke weil diese
Vorstellung des 20 Jahres die ist zu
Ende und die Zukunft ist auch nur für
die die loslassen können darum geht's
mir also ich will nur 20 €, das ist wir
müssen loslassen können und das darum
geht's wir müssen dafür werben dass man
loslassen
ja
und das ist genau
multikultierte haben uns eine riesen
Mauer wir können keine riesen- wir
werden keine riesen Mauer bauen können
aber indem wir den Menschen indem wir
heute auch uns selbst sagen und klar
machen was auf uns zukommt werden wir
auch unterschiedlich je nach Individuum
reagieren ich bin Unternehmen sie mal
Romane von Michelle wellbeck das ist
natürlich jetzt romanhaft
in romanhaft verklärt verzerrt ja aber
doch gibt es auch Europäer
die die mit den die unter den neuen
unter diesen extrem multikulturellen
Leben andere ziehen weg wir werden auch
so eine Domino Entwicklung haben wie wie
sie immer bei allen Wanderungsbewegungen
war die Einkommen rein dann wandern dann
wandern auch bestimmte heraus ja wer
sagt dass wir nicht im in der zweiten
Jahrhundert Hälfte Wanderungsbewegung
von Europa nach Osten haben zum Beispiel
nach Russland auf jeden Fall ein
positiveres Bild muss man sagen trotzdem
ihr neues Buch heißt das unheimliche
unheimlich ja
noch einmal zeigen haben diskutieren wir
zu viel dass die Politik zu sehr auf
Moral setzt und zu wenig auf Realität
das ist jetzt natürlich ein harter
Übergang
wasserübergang
und nach diesem Thema kommt mir
natürlich das was ich hier mitgebracht
habe als Problem ein bisschen banal vor
weil ich jetzt immer noch darüber
nachdenke wie das nächste Jahrhundert
wird aber tatsächlich
aber trotzdem gibt es ja auch Probleme
Hier und Jetzt und da glaube ich
tatsächlich dass die die
Moralisierung von allem und jedem zu der
schlechten politischen Stimmung der
vergangenen Jahre wahnsinnig beigetragen
hat es hat also es gab schon vorher aber
ganz doll angefangen hat es in der
corona-krise also als wir permanent
belehrt wurden also nicht darüber wie
man seine Hände wäscht und so sondern
mit so Fersen wie meine Disziplin ist
unsere beste Medizin also was mich immer
als Pionier Gelöbnis erinnert hat auf
groß Plakaten bespaßt wurden Bescheid
wurden von der von der Bundesregierung
damals noch große Koalition das geht
jetzt so weiter z.B mit zwei Riesen
Kampagnen einmal das
Wirtschaftsministeriums und dann das
Gesundheitsministeriums die darüber
informieren der Winter kommt es wird
kalt man kann sich anstecken
man muss heizen wenn wir wir müssen alle
zusammenhalten meine Mama braucht mich
also lauter Slogans die reinwerblich
sind keinerlei Informationsgehalt haben
und uns mal schlappe also gute 80
Millionen Euro kosten nur diese zwei
es sind eben es ist keine Informationen
also die Informationen die mal aus dem
Hause Haarwerk aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium heraustragen dass
das Entlüften der Heizung irgendwie sehr
viel bringt noch mal an zusätzliche
einspar Kapazität da würde ich sogar
noch sagen habe ich mir jetzt nie groß
Gedanken darüber gemacht in Gottes Namen
sagt uns das noch mal ansonsten sollen
Regierung informiert über das was sie
tun und gerne von mir aus auf der Seite
des Wirtschaftsministeriums über
Energiesparmöglichkeiten aber sie sollen
nicht nicht Propaganda also moralisch
aufgeladene Propaganda fürs impfen und
fürs Heizung runter drehen machen genau
das tun sie und das wird immer mehr und
meine Wahrnehmung ist es geht auch immer
mehr Leuten wahnsinnig auf die Nerven
und es korrespondiert übrigens einer
anderen Beobachtung die Journalisten
vielleicht teilen werden das nämlich das
pressesprecherwesen bei den Ministerien
und bei der beim Bundeskanzleramt
wahnsinnig zunehmen hatten sie in so
einem Haus einen Pressesprecher heute
haben sie vier sechs acht Pressesprecher
in den Häusern und die tun nicht das was
man so erwarten würde als Laie nämlich
dass sie dass sie den Journalisten also
Fragen beantworten und Ihnen damit
helfen ihren demokratischen Auftrag zu
erfüllen nämlich die Öffentlichkeit zu
informieren und auch zu beurteilen was
eine Regierung tut sondern die sind auf
Abwehr ausgerichtet sie kriegen keine
vernünftige Antwort mehr auf keinem Haus
ist es wirklich nur also der Sport also
Journalisten Fragen abwehren und aktiv
auf die Bürger zugehen aber eben nicht
mit mit sozusagen sachlichen Argumenten
und Informationen sondern mit moralisch
aufgeladene Agentin auch vorher Männer
behandelt die Politik manchmal die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wie so kleine
Kinder also ich merke einen Mangel an
Empathie ganz drastisch und so einen
zweiten diese Wartenburg Mentalität ne
wir machen jetzt mal den den Wagenburg
zu die Indianer können gerne umschreiben
wir schießen zurück ne das ist er erbt
aus früheren vielleicht schon Jahrzehnte
zurückliegenden Zeiten bei den Grünen
z.B kann ich mir das gut vorstellen wo
man dachte man wäre so ein
gesellschaftlicher Underdog muss ich da
irgendwie abschirmen aber das ist Tennis
wenn man regiert ist man für die ganzen
über 80 Millionen Leute zuständig ob
einem die passen oder nicht und das
stört mich sehr an dieser Regierung
diese wardenburgmentalität die haben
jetzt eine Menge Probleme gehabt die
Vorgängerregierungen auch nicht
angepackt haben das haben sie aber
gewusst die waren ja vorher auch schon
im Bundestag und können ja wollen
Haushalt lesen und die SPD war dabei ja
die SPD war dabei noch schlimmer so und
das zweite ist meiner Meinung nach dass
ganz viele jetzt auch nicht genau wissen
was man machen kann aber in der Politik
willst du ja sofort als Loser wenn du
mal zukommst dazu gibst dass du nicht
genau weiß was man jetzt als nächstes
machen muss
aber jetzt alle mit der Stange im Nebel
unterwegs jeder von uns ähm und ähm da
müssen wir überlegen wie man das sofort
kommen das auf der einen Seite
nicht verspricht oder nicht halten kann
auf der anderen Seite herstellt das ist
im Moment die Herausforderung an jeden
in der Regierung und da braucht man
wahrscheinlich die besten Köpfe weil das
echt schwer ist glauben Sie denn Herr
Fassbender dass man mit solchen
Werbekampagnen wie sie Frau Gaschke
jetzt gerade angesprochen
die zum einen viel Steuergeld kosten
aber wirklich auch Bürger beeinflussen
kann das hat doch jeder sein eigenes
Hirn und kann sagen also das sehe ich
anders also ich stelle mir gerade vor
wenn wir hier wir reden jetzt hier fast
eine Stunde über wirklich über
Realitäten ja sind wir nicht alle immer
einer sehen wenn manchmal aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven und so weiter
war vor allem wenn es um die Zukunft
geht wenn hier vier Politiker sie essen
würden wahrscheinlich über was weiß ich
schöne Worte reden alle allein schon
diese Konzentration auf Sprachregelungen
ja mein Eindruck ist die Politiker sind
viel zu sehr von von den Medien
beherrscht und sind die machen machen
ihr Ding für die Medien nicht für die
Bürger ja die Medien sind viel wichtiger
als die Bürger waren so Sprache Regelung
bloß nicht das falsche Wort sagen was
hat der der
Badezimmer gerade erzählt hat ist es für
die Medien immer schwieriger
Informationen zu kriegen erscheint
vielleicht eher so als seien sie um ihr
Leben natürlich die Medien heute und das
Stichwort Wagenburg das kann doch voll
unterschreiben die Medien sind dominiert
von einer bestimmten Sichtweise auf die
Welt nicht von einer bestimmten
Weltanschauung die sie für
fortschrittlich halten die Medien haben
sehr genau definiert was rückständig ist
das sind meistens geht es um
Sprachregelungen was man was man sagen
muss und was man nicht sagen darf aber
nicht die Bild ne
auch mal zurück aber
es gibt sie beide jetzt also ihre Häuser
doch nur weil wir seit einigen Jahren
bereits ein gegenläufigen Prozess
Erleben der aber auf die Politik noch
nicht wirklich zurückschlägt aber die
sind ich lese in den Leitmedien im
sogenannten Leitmedien immer noch die
Helme darüber das Bild TV nicht so viele
Zuschauer hat wie es doch eigentlich
gerne hätte das also wir wir als
Leitmedien unsere Dominanz weiterhin
erfolgreich verteidigen unsere Wagenburg
definiert und dann hat Medium
ganz genau
Europa
auf Twitter das alles ja
meinungskorridor und und nur einige die
da so ein bisschen versuchen dazu quer
auch zu argumentieren und an anderen
Sound zu haben aber es gibt natürlich
auch ein wahnsinnigen Binnendruck in den
Parteien genau
das wollen wir dafür ist viertel nach
acht da und deswegen bedanke ich mich
jetzt wir sind leider schon am Ende
unsere Runde glaube ich sich nicht
aufhalten lässt zu diskutieren ich danke
Ihnen vor allem fürs zusehen 8:15 Uhr
wir sehen uns morgen abend wieder schön
dass Sie dabei waren und ganz großen
Dank an meine Gäste bis dann
[Musik]